janelle i did not expect to talk to you
so early in the game the bb
queen i mean from a scale one to ten how
pissed off are you right now
oh i'm not pissed at all i'd be a solid
one um
totally get it i knew going into the
house
and i was even apprehensive of doing the
season in general
because i knew you know the name i am
like
all that stuff like over the years has
just been
pumped into these you know newer players
minds that i am
you know this big player so
i'm not surprised at all i knew i was a
bigger target than caser
knew i was definitely going home you did
you did
and and let's talk about that because
there's something called janelle
jennelly
and janellis it's a term that people are
using that people are jealous of you and
we saw it
with the people we saw with danny
everyone was talking about you all the
time in the house did you feel the
janelle see
um i feel it every season i participate
in
really every yes i that term actually
started 15 years ago
wow it's an analysis term do you know
what i'm completely flattered i mean
yeah i don't know what i do whatever but
i get these people
all excited and you know talking
i make the show what you're saying
that's why they keep asking me back and
you made it so interesting that
you got evicted on the 200th day in the
big brother house
your name was trending fans were going
crazy by the idea of you being evicted
do you feel that energy do you
understand how much the fans love you
with being part of big brother i
absolutely know that my fan base
is super hardcore i did i came back this
season
for the fans i was like you know they
asked me for
they also they were like will you come
back for all stars and i was hesitant
because i was like you know i don't want
to
hopefully you know there was going to be
some huge targets like a dan a derrick a
paul whatever
i was like okay like if it's all stars
like i have like
a little bit of a chance of making it
more than six weeks if i'm not like
the only like huge name in the house
so i did it for the fans i did it just
to like
my last hurrah like i've obviously done
so many seasons and i was like
another all-star season like sure let's
do it
and and i do it i did it for the fans
because they love
watching play every season so you know
i'm sorry i let them down
like that kind of no not at all and does
that mean this is it you don't want to
do big brother again
um i feel like my big brother time
is is done now i mean if they were to
ask me back for a shortened season
or something like that then yes but
it's been 15 years i mean i've done
i think ian figured out the percentage
because he's you know very intelligent
man i spent
1.4 of my life
okay so i'm good
you're good and then you come out of the
house and julie tells you some truth
about memphis the fact that he was uh
he's part of the alliance and you were
surprised by in
and i think he had an indication when he
went into the safety suite when he
didn't really
acknowledge that he was going to save
you and he threw the game
uh the competition uh how surprised
worried that he was using you
i mean not true i mean using me
a little surprise because i felt like i
did have a good connection with memphis
like just personal like outside of the
whatever like we just kind of gelled so
but i knew in the key room when he when
i asked if he'd play
to save me he's not a great liar
so i knew he was lying to me i knew he
threw the competition
and i mean at that point i knew i can't
trust memphis
so yeah and it's part of playing the
game and then there's nicole
uh man just let it out like there is a
lot of hostility
between you need to in the house i mean
what caused it
um things from another show you know the
amazing race
gets back bro things get brought back up
inside the big brother house
so there was like a little crack early
on and that just like amplified
and basically fell apart because i never
trusted nicole
and she's always been very insecure with
me
um just because i'm like a strong woman
or whatever
i just don't put up with any [ __ ] i
don't do the crying crap
i don't do the whining um
that kind of stuff irritates me
obviously so
i think she was always threatened or
scared by me she was scared of me
she was scared of you so does that mean
you're not going to her wedding
i'm not going to her wedding my girls
have a cheer competition that weekend
and others did so i'm not petty
i'm i want to keep it classy i will send
her a gift
and i wish this would be the gift i
don't know yet i mean i got to see the
registry and you know i'm not going to
give her
something crappy it'll just be like a
nice simple gift
it's not going to be from tiffany's or
anything
and then there's danny uh who didn't
vote for you she
voted for caser and uh there was a point
in the diary room where she said she
pretty much want well she was implying
that she wants to become the big brother
queen so
were you surprised she voted for you or
do you think this was a strategy and
trying to blame it on bailey
i think it's strategy to blame it on
someone else
or you know maybe look like
she's not with her lines because
everyone knows about the alliance in the
house
everyone knows that she approached me
because i let them know
she approached me to join her alliance
she named the people in her alliance and
she asked me in case
to join it so i let everyone know i mean
danny's in an alliance um
is that great gameplay
did you leave clothes back for bailey
did you actually lend her some clothes
is that right
i i left i gave a lot of my clothing to
devon
and bailey um both of them
my all-stars attire lots of stars on
them
um just cute little things that they can
remember me by
yeah yeah nicole can remember you too
while they wear your beautiful dresses i
think it's very smart on your part i
like that
you're still in the house one way or
another and you know
and that you know the fact is case
you're still in the house is the first
time he's
in the house and without you and are you
nervous now knowing what memphis is all
about and do you feel like he's gonna
get far
i do feel like memphis will get far yes
uh caser has an uphill battle i mean at
this point
um really uphill like
caser could be nominated this week i'm
sure
um i just worry about him because he
does tell
i think out of the two of us i trusted
memphis more than caser
but like he's still gonna tell memphis
things even though
we know that we can't trust memphis
because he threw the competition
and knew he was lying when he said he
would save us all that crap so we just
kind of think
our impression this week was just that
memphis was just a joke it's like
whatever
so yeah what what does this friendship
mean to you
oh case or everything um it was so nice
to it's weird because it's
the most interesting relationship i've
ever had
whatever reason in the big brother house
i have this
relationship with this man that is like
so solid and like we trust each other so
much
it's obviously platonic but it works in
the big brother house and that's
as sad as it is it's only when we play
big brother
so it's like one of those friendships
that's like
we connect in another way in the big
brother house
that i've never connected with yeah it's
like you're surviving right like it's
almost like a survival mode where you
start meeting with someone that's
important to you you know what kind of
sucks for me is the fact that i talked
to three women
in the last three weeks and you see
these alpha dogs
like you see cody memphis and tyler
uh how are you feeling about that
especially in this season
it's sad um yeah i wanted a woman to win
i want women to do better in the game
historically they don't do well
i'm extreme
[Music]
i don't know how i can say this sort of
offending people but i wish they would
have
cast stronger women in general for the
season that could have done something
you know rachel riley's pregnant if she
were in there
they would have been just as scared of
her as they were of me yeah
um you know there's other people there's
just
the i'm sorry but nicole franzel is like
not
she is the kind of person that targets
women so
it's it's a cat like you need to cast
strong women that's
it that's what you have to do so who do
you want to win at the end of the game
oh um you know i think
danny or memphis will win but i would
love to see
bailey ian um
even devon win yeah and who do you not
want to win
nicole franco i know i don't even know
why i asked that question
you know through this process and the
fact that you mentioned that you've been
on it
so much what have you learned about
yourself this time around
um so this time around i feel like
so i feel like physically the game was
harder for me
this time around but mentally it was so
much easier
because right age comes wisdom right
so i felt like stronger mentally way way
stronger
way more insightful in the game when
people are lying to me when people are
playing me it's like i pick up on little
things
i didn't have that skill when i was 25
but 25 i was more capable physically if
that makes sense
and so what does big brother mean now in
your life now that you're telling me
you're not going to do it again
what has it meant for you big brother
has always been
you know the most amazing experience
i've ever done
um it's you know it has shaped me a
little bit in who i
am and i'm forever grateful
that i was cast 15 years ago to do the
show
um it means the world to me i love that
you are amazing it sucks that you're out
of the house but uh you were so
entertaining so thank you so much for
chatting with us today